lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
hablar sobre el fenómeno de la luz
que al menos para mí es misteriosa ya
que en un nivel define nuestra realidad
quizá es una de las características que
más definen nuestra realidad todo lo que
vemos cómo percibimos la realidad se
basa en la luz siendo rebotada por los
objetos o doblándose acerca de objetos o
siendo disfrutada por objetos siendo
percibida por nuestros ojos los cuales
envían señales a nuestro cerebro y éste
crea modelos de las cosas que nos rodean
así que es una característica que define
nuestra realidad pero también cuando
realizamos experimentos con la luz y la
analizamos con más detalle nos
encontramos que tiene unas propiedades
misteriosas y en gran medida aún no es
totalmente comprendida una de las muchas
cosas sorprendentes de la luz y eso no
sólo es característico de la luz sino de
cualquier cosa que observamos a un nivel
cuántico pero en el caso de la luz ésta
se va a comportar tanto como ondas
y como particular
artículo
y esto probablemente no es tan intuitivo
para ustedes ya que tampoco es intuitivo
para mí en mi vida estoy acostumbrada a
ciertas cosas que se comporten como onda
como las ondas de sonido o las ondas en
el océano y también estoy acostumbrada a
ciertas cosas que se comporten como
partículas como el básquetbol o como mi
taza de café no estoy acostumbrada a ver
cosas que se comporten de ambas formas
así que realmente depende del
experimento que usemos como percibimos
la luz cuando lo observamos como
partícula nos encontramos con lo que
einstein investigó en su trabajo del
efecto fotoeléctrico que no veremos en
detalle aquí quizás más adelante en otro
vídeo cuando comencemos a pensar en
mecánica cuántica lo veamos así que
podemos ver la luz como un tren de
partículas las cuales se mueven a la
velocidad de la luz de lo cual
hablaremos en un momento y
estas partículas las llamamos fotones
fotones si vemos la luz como una onda si
vemos la luz reflejada en un prisma como
en este ejemplo veremos a la luz como
una onda y tendrá las propiedades de una
onda va a tener una frecuencia y una
longitud de onda como las otras ondas y
así también podemos calcular su
velocidad como en las demás ondas su
velocidad es la frecuencia por la
longitud de onda y aún si ignoramos este
comportamiento como de partículas y nos
concentramos en el aspecto del
comportamiento de onda de la luz nos
encontraríamos que esto sigue siendo
fascinante ya que la mayor parte de las
ondas requieren un medio para viajar por
ejemplo si yo me fijo en cómo es que el
sonido viaja a través del aire
suponiendo que estas son las partículas
que hay en el aire por dónde va a
transmitirse una onda de sonido y lo que
va a hacer esta onda de sonido es que va
a comprimir algunas de estas moléculas
de aire
y estas partículas que se comprimieron a
su vez se van a comprimir con las
partículas que tienen juntos por lo que
en el aire tendremos áreas podemos decir
con mayor presión y áreas con menos
presión incluso podríamos dibujarlas así
las áreas con mayor presión van a ser
así y luego van a haber áreas con baja
presión mayor presión menos presión y
conforme estas partículas golpean entre
sí y nuestra onda va viajando digamos
que hacia la derecha veríamos a esta
onda de sonido viajando hacia la derecha
pero todo esto se basa con la energía
que se va transmitiendo en este medio y
yo estoy acostumbrada a visualizar las
ondas de esta manera pero la luz no
necesita de un medio para viajar así que
la luz no necesita
para viajar de hecho la luz viaja más
rápido cuando se encuentra en el vacío
cuando viaja a través de nada y viaja a
una velocidad increíble viaja a 3 por 10
a la 8 metros por segundo sólo para que
se den una idea
estos son 300 millones de metros en un
segundo otra forma de ver esto es que a
la luz le tomaría menos de una séptima
parte de un segundo viajar alrededor de
la tierra o viajar siete veces alrededor
de la tierra en un segundo así que es
algo tremendamente rápido y esta no es
sólo una velocidad tremendamente rápida
también nos dice que la luz es algo
fundamental en nuestro universo ya que
no sólo tiene una velocidad inimaginable
tiene la velocidad
rápida no sólo físicamente sino en toda
la física nada puede viajar más rápido
que la velocidad de la luz y esto es
otra cosa que es poco intuitiva para
nosotros al menos en nuestro día a día
imaginen que algo va a cierta velocidad
y no se tiene una hormiguita arriba que
está yendo todavía más rápido encima de
este objeto que se está moviendo así que
si se estuviera moviendo en la misma
dirección
nuestra hormiguita estaría yendo más
rápido pero nada puede viajar más rápido
que la luz esto es completamente
imposible al menos con nuestro
entendimiento actual de la física así
que no es sólo una velocidad rápida es
la velocidad más rápida que puede haber
la más rápida que puede existir
y esto de aquí es una aproximación es
2.98 y algo más por 10 a la 8 metros por
segundo pero 3 por 10 a la 8 metros por
segundo es una buena aproximación y
dentro del espectro de luz visible y en
un momento voy a explicar a qué me
refiero con esto del espectro visible
ustedes sin duda están familiarizados
con los colores pueden imaginarse un
arco iris el arco iris ocurre cuando la
luz del sol la luz blanca del sol está
haciendo refractada por un prisma o en
el caso de los arco iris pues por
pequeñas gotas de agua y eso lo podemos
ver más claramente cuando tenemos la luz
blanca refractada con un prisma como lo
tenemos aquí las diferentes longitudes
de onda de la luz ya que la luz blanca
contiene a todos estos colores cada
longitud de onda o cada color se
refracta de manera diferente al menos
por un prisma como es en el caso de esta
imagen las longitudes de onda de alta
frecuencia el violeta y el azul
se refracta en más por lo que su
dirección se va a doblar más al menos se
va a retractar más que las otras
longitudes de onda como lo son el rojo y
el amarillo y si quieren ver la longitud
de onda de la luz o al menos la parte
visible de la luz se encuentra entre los
400 nanómetros y los 750 nanómetros y
mientras mayor sea la frecuencia como en
esta sección tendrá más energía la onda
una mayor frecuencia significa que cada
uno de estos fotones tiene más energía
tiene una mayor habilidad de pasar
energía cinética y golpear electrones y
sacarlos de sus órbitas vamos a
escribirlo mayor frecuencia
a mayor frecuencia
significa mayor
energía
mayor energía y bueno me sigo refiriendo
a esta idea de la luz visible y se dan
cuenta que la luz es parte de un
fenómeno mucho más grande si quisiéramos
ampliar la discusión de esto podríamos
decir que la luz visible es sólo una
parte del espectro electromagnético así
que la luz es solamente radiación
electromagnética es radiación
radiación
electro magnética
electromagnética
y lo que hablamos de la luz hace un
momento sobre las propiedades como onda
y las propiedades como partícula no son
exclusivas de la luz visible se aplican
a todo el espectro de radiación
electromagnética a frecuencias muy bajas
o longitudes de onda muy grandes
hablamos de cosas como las ondas de
radio que es lo que nos permite escuchar
el radio de nuestro auto por ejemplo lo
que permite que nuestros teléfonos
celulares se comuniquen con las torres
celulares tenemos también las microondas
que son las cosas que hacen que
comiencen a vibrar las moléculas de agua
en nuestra comida para que comiencen a
calentarse y se cocinen también tenemos
el infrarrojo que es lo que genera
nuestro cuerpo con el calor y por eso
podemos detectar personas a través de
muros mediante cámaras infrarrojas
tenemos la luz visible y la luz
ultravioleta la radiación ultravioleta
que viene del sol y que hace que nos
bronce mos o que incluso se nos queme la
piel tenemos los rayos x- que es la
radiación que atraviesa el material
suave
nos permite visualizar los huesos y
tenemos rayos gamma radiación de muy
alta energía que se genera de cuásares y
otros fenómenos físicos
todos estos son ejemplos de exactamente
la misma cosa y sucede que nosotros solo
percibimos una parte de estas
frecuencias lo que conocemos como luz
visible y ustedes me pueden decir bueno
como es posible que nos hayamos adaptado
a observar justamente estas frecuencias
estas frecuencias y acá y pongo entre
comillas ver es lo que podemos ver así
directamente con nuestros ojos y la
razón o al menos lo que yo creo que es
la mejor razón que explica esto es
porque estas son las frecuencias en las
que nuestro sol genera mayor radiación
electromagnética si viven en la tierra
su especie se va a adaptar mejor a
observar las cosas con base en la
energía que reflejan o la energía
electromagnética que reflejan y es más
útil percibir a aquellas cosas que
reflejan la mayor cantidad de radiación
electromagnética y es posible que en
otras realidades o en otros planetas hay
especies que perciban más por ejemplo de
la luz ultravioleta o del extremo
infrarrojo
incluso hay en la tierra ciertos
organismos que funcionan mejor en alguno
de estos extremos
pero resulta que nosotros podemos ver
mejor en el conjunto de frecuencias que
coincide con que el sol genera más
energía
vamos a dejarlo aquí creo que esta fue
una buena introducción al tema y si
cualquiera de estas cosas que vimos
durante este vídeo les parece poco
intuitiva o confusa
esta dualidad de partícula y onda que
representa la luz la idea de la
transferencia de energía a través de un
vacío si todo esto les parece poco
intuitivo no se preocupen no son los
únicos que están así esto es poco
intuitivo incluso para el mejor de los
físicos así que no se preocupen ustedes
ya se encuentran en la punta del
pensamiento físico